Inuit were born to be outside my
earliest memories of growing up with my
family was connected to the land using
dog-teams skin tents hi ox he lived on
the land you took what you needed we
didn't have electric power we didn't
have modern conveniences of any sort we
just lived a very simple and happy
content leaf you would never forget
where we came from the values that we
were taught without those values and
those skills we would never have
survived
we've seen a lot of changes in the north
in 50 60 years
as a traditional Inuit hunter I still
try to harvest and utilize the Landin to
see as the way we did but the world has
changed I feel such an honor in such a
privilege to be able to connect with
Inuit in Greenland Nunavut Nunavut and
the new viola with origins as a hunter
or as a carver we try to share stories
we try to share what more harvesting
methods and means what's available
at the end of the day they're all our
cousins were all connected that's one
thing that I don't want us to lose our
culture has to be practiced in order to
be strong
[Music]